نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان
اموس وكستين مستشار الرئيس الامريكي اقترح
ان تصدر اسرائيل بيانا تعلن فيه الانتقال
الى عمليات اقل شده في غزه بما يساعد على
تهدئه الوضع في لبنان واضاف المسؤولون ان
مستشار بايدن ابلغ رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي انه يريد بداء مفاوضات غير
مباشره بشان الحدود مع لبنان بمجرد توقف
الاشتباكات بين اسرائيل وحزب الله ونقل
الموقع عن متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان مستشار بايدن سيلتقي اليوم في
بيروت رئيس الوزراء اللبناني نجيب ميقاتي
ومسؤولين في الحكومه والجيش وقال المتحدث
ان لقاءات هوك ستاين في بيروت تهدف لتعزيز
البحث بشان كيفيه التوصل الى تفاهمات
لاستعاده الهدوء على الحدود مع
اسرائيل